la réforme veut simplifier les
procédures civiles et pénales
mais les avocats critiquent la méthode
c'est la ligne politique de macron ce
qu'il est en train de nous dire au
niveau du ministère de la justice est je
vous entends vos préoccupations sont
légitimes mais je ne change rien ce que
on est en train de faire faut pas se
leurrer c'est ce qui a été fait à b avec
l'armée c'est ce qui a été fait aussi
avec les services publics de la santé
vous gardez des coquilles vous garder un
certain nombre de services et puis petit
à petit vous enlever des services et au
bout d'un moment il reste plus qu'une
structure vide et bats la structure vie
d'après elle est appelée à disparaître
je ne vois pas comment ça pourrait être
pire qu'en ce que ce qu'on nous propose
aujourd'hui parce que ce qui nous est
proposé aujourd'hui c'est un projet qui
est fait par des gens qui ne mettent
jamais les pieds dans un palais de
justice mme les avocats voit dans le
projet de réforme une justice
déshumanisé servant une logique purement
comptable
quand vous allez proposer aux gens de
dire mais si justice doit vous êtes
rendu vous allez venir assure une borne
électronique par exemple scanner les
documents et vous recevrez décision par
la poste
l'humanité en tant qu'avocat on la voit
on la sent fin c'est nous qui sommes
directement en lien avec les
justiciables et si on l'exclût des
tribunaux
c'est inquiétant parce que si on le juge
ne peut pas prendre une décision sans
cette dimension humaine on vient au
tribunal non pas comme on va au marché
on vient il ya un instant de solennité
et vous avez quelqu'un qui effectivement
représente une fonction et vous avez de
l'audience qui est là pour pouvoir
permettre aux gens de s'exprimer de
comprendre d'entendre l'autre est un
moment donné de se dire justice a été a
été rendue afin de ne pas pénaliser les
justiciables les avocats retournent à
leur dossier dès ce jeudi leur
mobilisation continue sans faire grève
afin de maintenir la pression en
direction de la chancellerie